Hi, everyone. Welcome to the sixth
tutorial in our "Imaging Science Series"
here at the MIT Museum. For today's video,
we have a special guest,
Jeffrey Kuhn, who is the scientific
director of the Koch Institute's
Microscopy Core Facility here at MIT.
He's going to discuss what exactly is a
digital image and how we can use that
knowledge to make adjustments to those
images and to show things that we
wouldn't have otherwise seen. With
that, I'm going hand it over to Jeffrey. [Jeffrey] In this video, we're going to be talking
about scientific images, some of the most
important features of them, and how you
process them. I'm going to give you a
little bit of background information
first, on what scientific images are and
some of the basic features that we are
going to need to understand in order to
bring out more information from these
images.
So, what are the main things we look for
in a scientific image? Well, the first
thing we look for is whether or not you
can see what you want to see. This is
dictated by the contrast; whether
something is visible in the first place.
We also want to know if we have enough
information to distinguish things
and that's resolution. We typically
think of resolution in terms of
megapixels in your camera, but there's a
scientific definition of resolution -- that
is, can you distinguish two things as
separate or not? There's also how much
uncertainty there is in your measurement;
how clear your image is. Every
measurement you take has uncertainty. If
you measure the temperature over the
course of a day, your uncertainty might
be a few degrees Fahrenheit. So, images
are no different. There is an uncertainty
in the measurement of intensities of an
image. In imaging, we use the
signal-to-noise ratio. If noise is the
uncertainty in your measurement, the
signal is what you want to see, we tend
to measure the ratio between those two
things to tell us how clear our
certainty is. Then, finally, there's
the speed of which you take an
image. That's called temporal resolution.
Did you capture the right moment in
time?
So, you can't have good contrast, good
resolution, good clarity, and fast speeds
all at once. There's always a compromise
between these factors. There's always a
balance you have to make and this is
called the "triangle of compromise." So, for
instance, if you want something that's
both bright and high resolution in
detail, you'll have to image very slowly.
If you want something that's very fast
imaging and high resolution, you won't be able to collect as much
light. It's going to be dimmer. If you
want something that's bright and fast,
you're going to have to sacrifice
spatial resolution, but you'll
end up with a blockier image.
We can, however, balance between these
factors. For most cameras, you can set the
exposure time for your images. So, if you
want to do a fast exposure to capture
fine motion, you can do that, but you'll
be getting a dimmer image and you might
have to sacrifice some detail. If you
want slower images, you can make them
brighter. Some cameras let you actually
change the resolution of the image,
basically putting a bunch of pixels
together into big super pixels. That
actually increases the sensor area the
pixels, makes them brighter. So, you can
get, at the expense of lower resolution,
you can get a brighter image. Or if you
want higher resolution, you're going to
deal with dimmer, or less light
collecting ability. Also, you can bounce
between these things by expense. So,
bigger sensors and bigger lenses
can collect more light, but that ends up
being more expensive. So, the camera
equipment that you use can dictate how
far along this "triangle of compromise"
you can go. So, digital image is
fundamentally a matrix of numbers that
describe intensities. So, we're going to
use this image of an old world ape mandrill
to talk about the numbers that make up
the intensities in an image. We're
going to ignore color for the time being
and just look at a black and white
version of this mandrill. So, let's take a
look at a little tiny portion of the
muzzle -- near this little red line on the
muzzle. If we blow up that little
portion that looks like a bunch of gray
squares. Those gray squares
are made up of a bunch of numbers. If
you look, the squares on the left-hand
side tend to be a little bit higher
value -- let's say 180-200, things like that.
Then those images are brighter, those
pixels are brighter. The ones on the
right-hand side are a little bit lower
value -- 111, 118 they tend to be darker. So,
the numbers in this matrix describe
intensities. So, how do computers
represent numbers? Well, we represent
numbers the Arabic way, or in powers of
10 and decimal digits. So, for instance, a
three-digit number has a ones place, a tens
place, and a hundreds place. For example, the number
136 is a one in a hundreds place, a three
in the tens place, and a six in the ones
place. You can sum all those together -- a
hundred, plus 30, plus six and that gives
you 136. Well, computers represent numbers
in a binary fashion. So, they use a single
number between zero or one to describe a
number. Each of these bits can go
from zero to one and they have different places -- a ones place, a twos place, a fours place,
etc. So, for instance, the number one can
be represented by a one in the ones
place and zero everywhere else. The
number 136 can be represented by a
number one in the 128 place and a one in
the 8th place and that adds together to
be 136. If you have all ones in one of
these eight bit values, the maximum number is
255. So, eight bits can have a maximum of
255 and a minimum of zero. It turns out
the more bits you use in one of these
images, the more shades of gray you can
represent. So, for instance, two bits can
represent four different shades of gray.
So, here's the mandrill with four shades
of gray. You can also use four bits, or 16
shades of gray.and now we're starting to
get a little bit more detail on this
mandrill. It doesn't look quite so chunky.
Eight bits gives you 256 shades of gray and
now this mandrill looks very smooth -- very
good detail in this mandrill. But
computers, and sometimes scientific
images, can actually take even more than
eight bits. They might have 16 bits of
of numbers in your image, so 65,000
shades. Or you might use color. Where in
most cases, most computers will use eight
bits per color -- so 256 shades of red, 256
shades of green, 256 shades of blue. Let's
look, now, at the difference between eight and
four bits. Let's zoom up on a little bit of
a portion of this. Now if you notice in
the four bit image, you can see the
gradations from gray to white in the
muzzle.
Whereas with 256 shades, you can't really
see much of a gradation at all. It looks
much smoother. So, it turned out somewhere
between that 16 shades and
256 shades, is about where your eyes can
distinguish individual shades of gray. So,
what makes a good image? These are
examples of cells taken by microscopes
and most of these have slightly
different contrasts. It's the
contrast that makes them better or worse.
So, for example, the cells on the top
left-hand side, the top left and the top
middle, are taken with the same
microscope using different contrast
methods. In this top left image, you can
barely start to see some cells and, in
the middle image, you can actually make
them out because they've got higher
contrast.
Similarly, this image of a cell on the
right hand side, has pretty good contrast
as well. Not quite as good as the one in
the middle. Then in the bottom row,
you're seeing good contrast between the
two bottom images. You're getting nice,
these are called microtubules -- they're
very bright against a dark background.
The one in the middle is less blurry
then the one on the left hand side. So,
blurring makes a little less, or worse
contrast. Then finally, color can add
additional detail of contrast for your
eye. So, let's talk about contrast.
Contrast is whether or not you can see
something in the first place. So, I've
drawn a bunch of dots on this slide and
those represent a signal, a signal that
we want. I put them on top of
different backgrounds and the background
is what we don't care about, or what we
don't really want. So, I've increased the
signal from going from left to right
hand side, and I've increased more and
more background going from top to bottom.
So, let's take a look at the left hand
side, the weakest signal. You can actually
start to see this weak signal on top of
a black background. But when you've got a
really bright, or white background, that
signal is almost gone. It turns out,
the definition of contrast is
essentially the signal you want minus the
background you don't care about divided by the
background. So, intuitively, what we
think about is that the more background
you have, the weaker the contrast. The
more signal you have, the higher the
contrast. So, the contrast increases from
left to right as we get more and more
signal and it increases from bottom to
top as we get lower and lower
background levels. To give you an example
of how background can effect contrast
tremendously. Stars are actually out
during the day. You just can't see them
because the sunlight is so bright and
that sky is so bright. But, once that
brightness goes away and day turns to
night, the stars, that were the same
signal they were before, are suddenly
visible because the background is no
longer there. So, background can affect
contrast tremendously. Now that we
understand contrast, let's talk about
what types of intensity values we're
going to display from an image. So most
monitors, and printers, and computers
store images as eight bits of intensity.
Higher grade scientific cameras, or if
you take a high dynamic, or a range, or
HDR photo, you might store those images
as 16 bits, or 16 bits as raw data. But,
most computers can only display eight bits
of information at any one time. So, what
ranges of values of that 16 bits are you
going to actually choose to display? Well,
if you have something that's really
bright, you might choose the topmost bits,
or the brightest bits to display and
scale those to eight bits that your
monitor, or computer, can display. If that
image is fairly dim, you might take the
dimmest pixels in that image and stretch
them into the eight bits that your monitor can display. But, that
same sort of transformation can also
apply to eight bit images. We can take a
range of those values from an eight bit
image and choose which range to display
on your monitor. So, in order to
understand what we're doing with this,
let's talk about how we analyze image
intensity. So, there's actually a way to
plot all of the image intensities in
your image and this is called a
histogram -- it's a plot of intensity
values. So, what we're going to do, is take
our mandrill example and that matrix of
numbers from that little tiny portion of
the muzzle and we're going to count the
intensities by range. So, let's take the
range of pixel values from 100 to 119. If
I count those out, go through all that
and count out, I get about 10 pixels from
that range. If I now go from 120 to 139
and count all those up, I get
thirteen. If I count from 140 to 159 intensity values,
there's only one of
those, so it's a very small number. From
160 to 179, I've got about 19 and etc, etc.
You can continue counting in these
bin ranges. Okay, so what does that
give us? If you'd look at those counts,
those tally marks, that looks kind of
like a graph. Turn that graph sideways
and plot it out for the entire image,
going from low intensities on the left,
or zero, all the way up to 255, to the
highest intensity and we're going to plot
the counts as a graph. This ends up
being called a histogram plot of all the
intensities. So, it's counts over the
entire range of intensities that are
possible. So, a histogram is actually a
very informative plot of what kind of
intensities are in our image. For
example, for this histogram, we can see
that there are very few black pixels and
there are very few white pixels. The
majority of these pixels are mostly gray,
centered right about the center of this
image of the intensity values. Let's take
a look at another image. So, this is an
image of a bunch of boats and we can see
that there is a bunch of high number of
black pixels. So, those black pixels
correspond to the bottoms of those boats.
There's also a bunch of gray pixels
that correspond to the sea, and the air,
and most of the boat, and a few little
wider and brighter pixels, as well. But,
this gives us an indication of what kind
of intensity values our images contain.
Even color histograms can tell us
something. So, I can take all of the
intensities in the red channel, the green
channel, and the blue channel and plot
those individual histograms. For
example, in the highest values at 255, you
see a lot of red, and just a little bit
of blue, and no green. Those
correspond to the bright red stripe
going down the center of the muzzle of
this mandrill. Just a little bit
below those, there is some fairly bright
blue, with no green, and a tiny little bit
of red, and blue and red together make up
magenta. So, this is the magenta and blue
stripes along the muzzle next to the
nose.
A little bit farther, or dimmer, you can
see a bunch of green, and a little bit of
red, and very little blue. This
corresponds to the yellow whiskers,
because red and green together make
yellow. So, we can get a little bit of
information from color from a histogram.
You can do the same sorts of plots
of intensities of color. So, how do we use
these histogram plots to bring out
information from an image? Well, let's
draw a line going from the bottom left
to the top right corner of this
histogram. We're going to use this
original histogram as the input and
we're going to create an output
histogram corresponding to the image
that we want. So, the bottom, or zero, in the input, corresponds to
zero in the output and 255, on the
input, corresponds to 255 in the output.
We call this transformation a linear
map. We're going linearly from 0 to 255
on the input, and that maps to
values from 0 to 255 on the output side.
But, what happens if we stretch this line,
or change the slope of this line? So,
let's take the minimum and raise it up,
and the maximum and lower it down. If
we stretch that image, we essentially,
are narrowing our contrast range to
what's actually in our image, to the
values, or brightness values, that are
actually in our image. So, we can actually
make a better contrast image of this
mandrill. But, we don't have to stick to a
line. We can also use a curve to describe
a transfer function from input to output.
So, you can use a curve, to the bottom
right, for instance, to get rid of some of
the darker values, while keeping some of
the brighter values. Or you can use a
curve, to the upper left, to boost the
darker values without really increasing
the bright values as much. So, we can use
these tools -- the histogram, and these
transfer functions, and our minimum, our
maximum, and our gamma, to bring out
information and to get the most out of
our scientific images. So, let's use our
newfound knowledge of image intensity
values and histograms to try and bring
out some more information from some
scientific images. So, we're going to be using the
free image manipulation program called
GIMP -- it stands for the "new image
manipulation program." But, most of the
other software packages you might run
across will have the same sort of
histogram manipulation screens that you
can use to bring out intensity
information and hidden information from
scientific images. So, I'm going to use GIMP
and I'm going to drag one file on to
this image manipulation program. So,
what we have here, are a bunch of stars
taken against a black mountain. Right. So,
let's see if we can bring out some other
information from this particular photo.
So, we're going to go to the main histogram
window for adjusting and doing these
maps. So, there are two that we want to
talk about in GIMP. We're going to talk
about, under the colors, menu there's
something called levels, and there's
something called curves. So, these two
menu items, right here, will let us
manipulate the histogram. So, let's start
with levels.
Okay, so, levels shows a histogram of the
intensity values within this image.
So, you can see, this is our histogram. We're
going from dark pixels, to bright pixels
and we're seeing a count of dark to
bright pixels. Now, let's take a look.
There are two basic comps and the first
thing I'm gonna do, is take this maximum
value and drag it down all the way to
about where we start to see stuff. Well,
guess what? Now we can start to see, we've
got these dim stars in the background
and by just changing the intensity
levels, we're able to bring out some of
the information that was hidden to our
eyes in this image. So, we can now see the
Milky Way, we can now see more
more stars, and we can start to
see this mountain right here.
Let's bring the intensity down a little
bit more. Now the stars are really
bright, and now, we're starting to see a
little bit of this mountain. So, it looks
like, if we look at this histogram, most
of this line, most of this, comes from the
mountain, and most of this hump
comes from the stars. So, we could bring
out the stars at the expense of the
mountain and, remember, if we drop the
background down, we can get a little bit
better contrast. So, if we want to focus
on the stars and the Milky Way galaxy
portions, sitting right across your image,
we can bring the bottom a little bit up
and that decreases the apparent
background. So I'm just going to zoom in.
I'm going to hit "plus" on the keyboard and
we can start to see individual stars. All
right.
So, we brought out some hidden
information in this image. Let's take a
look at a couple of other images. So,
let's take a look at a daytime image.
Let's see if we can actually see some
stars in this and I bet you...(get rid of this and open it up) . I think we
can see anything inside this image. So,
I'm going to bring up, again, colors, levels.
Right now, this bright stuff here is
showing the sky and the brightest
portions of the image. But, this histogram
is really, really dim it's really hard to
see because the counts are linear.
There's a little button up here and a
lot of your software programs will
have something like this. It makes up
what's called a "logarithmic histogram." So,
this basically expands the histogram out
so you can see more of what's happening.
Again, now this logarithmic histogram,
if I drag down, we can't
see anything in the dark, because the
bright image is just too bright. Okay so,
we're not going to really be able to pull
out. Let's try dragging the bottom back
up. Okay. Let's change the background,
lower the background. Well, we still
can't see stars in this image and that's
fine. It's too
little contrast in our original image.
But, let's do one more thing. Let's go to
colors. Reset very quick, just to
get back to normal. I'm going to go to
color curves. Okay, so this, remember that
transfer function we talked about? Well,
we can decrease or increase the minimum
and turn a little bit more black. You can
also change to a curve.
We could potentially make this mountain
a little bit more contrasty by changing
the intensity curve. The fun thing
about this, is that you can actually put
multiple curves on your color
curve, you can put multiple inflection
points. Okay, but now that we understand
what's happening, it gives us a little bit
of a better grasp of what we're doing
with these sorts of intensity
transformation curves. All right. So, let's
see if we can bring out something else.
Let's start with another stars image. So,
let's drag another image onto here. Okay.
So, now, this image is from a 16-bit or
RAW format. So, the previous image right
here was only eight bits and let me take
a look. Let's go to image precision and
this is an eight bit integer image. Okay.
Let's go take a look on this. This, if we
look at image precision, this is 16 bit. So,
there's more information in this image
than there was in the previous image.
Okay, so let's bring up our color levels
again and take a look. Remember I
still got... this is the normal histogram.
Actually, let's go back to this linear
histogram versus the logarithmic
histogram. Let me click on the linear
histogram right here. Okay, so again, we're
seeing two humps -- one is a black hump and
one is a slightly less black hump. So, let's
bring our maximum down and,
again, we can start to see the stars.
So, we can see a lot of interesting
things in here. Again, I can bring the
minimum up and to just increase the
contrast of the sky, of this night sky. So
now we're seeing a little bit better
contrast here of the night sky. But we're
still washing this out a little bit.
Let's drop this back down. So, a little
bit of sunset left at this twilight
image. But, remember this little hump
right here? Let's move our minimum and
maximum to span that hump and guess what?
Look at that. Now, we see the mountain in
essentially, like daylight conditions.
The sixteen bits of information -- what
that means, is that
we're getting a lot more shades when
we're
looking at this tiny little range of our
input values. We're getting a lot more
shades out because there's more
information stored in the 16 bit image.
Okay, let's take a look at another image,
Let's see if we can pull out more star
images from, let's say, an eclipse. So, this
is the Sun during an eclipse and this
is not quite a full eclipse yet. Again, this image, if we take a look at
the precision, this is an eight bit image. So,
there might not be a lot hidden inside
this image, but we're gonna try anyway.
Let's go to levels and it looks like
there's just a tiny little bit of
information down here. Let's switch to a
logarithmic histogram. In reality, this is
logarithmic. There's not much information
right here,
but I can still drag this maximum down.
Now, the corona from the Sun is
peeking out a little bit more. We're
seeing more of that. But, in reality, we're
not really seeing much in terms of stars.
This image, the raw data, was
just too dim to get at the stars behind
this image. So, let's try another
eclipse image that's a little bit
farther along. So, this is at
a full eclipse and now this corona is
really bright because this image was
taken at a much longer exposure. Still,
it's an eight bit image but let's see what
we can bring out with the levels. Okay,
let's bring our maximum down. Okay? Now we're starting to see some things.
Here's something else I want to
point out. So, we're starting to see some
spots in the background. I am going to
have to zoom up to take a look at these.
I can hold down the spacebar
and use this to drag our image around. I
can use the plus key to zoom in, and the
minus key to zoom out, and the spacebar
to drag everything around. Okay, so now,
we're starting to see blobs right here.
This is a star. You can zoom up on it.
And I can tell that this is likely a
star because it takes up more than one
pixel. You notice in the background area
right here, there's a bunch of noise and
this is what happens with
low-light images. Your cameras just
generate a lot of noise and that tends
to be really low values of intensity, but
it's still there. When you're blowing up
the intensity like this, that noise comes
right out. You'll notice that
there are single points of noise right
here. It looks like individual pixels
might be bright surrounded by darker
things. That's an
indication that what that is, is noise --
things that tend to look square. Whereas,
do you see this, right here? This blob?
That is likely a star. This blob, right
here, is likely a star because it takes
up more than one pixel. It's taking up a
few pixels. So, that is a collection of
photons, a very dim collection of photons,
but a collection of photons, nonetheless,
that indicate that what you're looking
at is a star, and not noise. So, again,
there's less clarity to
this image because the signal here is
very weak, and the noise is very strong.
So, now let's look at a biological
image -- something a little bit less
astronomy. So, this is an image of a
flower and let's see if we can find
something else on this flower. So, I'm
going to go to color level. Let's take a
look at our histogram. It's a little bit
low, so I'm going to switch to a logarithmic,
so I could see more of the values right
here. Okay. Typically what I do, when
I'm looking in a scientific image, is I
will play around with the minimum, and
I'll drag that up and down, and see if I
can see anything new.
There's something that's poking out.
I can drag the maximum
down a little bit and see if I could see
anything at the dim portions. Okay,
so, let's drag up this minimum. You're
starting to see something with a little
bit more contrast. It looks like there's a
caterpillar on this flower. We can
bring it out with just
manipulating the histogram and this
transfer function, the input versus
output levels. Similarly, let's take a
look at these petals. So, I'm going to
zoom up on a petal.
These petals are fairly dark. They're
darker than the center of the flower.
Let's zoom back out. So, the petals here
surrounding, and even this black space,
the flower is really bright. But
sometimes, if you're looking for
something really bright in an image, it's
going to overwhelm the dark stuff that
you might be interested in seeing. So, I'm
going to drag this top portion down and see
if I can bring out some detail at the
darker levels. Now, at the darker levels,
you're starting to see, potentially,
pollen on this flower. You can see
the veins on the flower
petals a little bit clearer.
And let's just compare that to dragging all the way up. So, sometimes the
information you're looking at, is hidden
in dark information. You can
sacrifice bright pixels, and bright
portions of your data, in order to look
at the dimmer stuff. So, that will,
hopefully, give you a little bit of an
idea of how to bring information out of
scientific photos. To look for the hidden
side in the images you took and to
understand what image intensity levels,
and histograms, and these transfer
functions can show you with scientific
images. [Brian] Thank you for joining us for this
tutorial in our "Imaging Science Series"
with the MIT Museum and Koch Institute.
We'd love to see your stunning science
photos. If you'd like to share them with
us you can share them on Facebook, Twitter,
and Instagram and use the hashtag #MITMImagingScience to share those with us.
At the end of this program, so on June
20th, we'll be holding a webinar to look
at what makes a great science photo and
some of those submissions have a chance
to be featured during that webinar. For
more information on the "Imaging Science
Program," other tutorials, and other
information and resources, please visit
the MIT Museum website at the link below
and you will find a list of our other
resources as part of the "Imaging Science
Program."